first story Santos is coming to
fortnight oh when I heard this I was
like what wait a minute
sorry sorry can you repeat that who's
coming to fourth-dan else is coming to
fortnight Santos Santos is coming for
tonight yeah you big purple purple bad
guy with the bald head yeah he's got
like seven crevices in his chin looked
kind of nasty but got a nasty chin but
he's come in a fortnight um all right so
what if this is is an event called
Infinity Gauntlet limited-time mashup
and it kicks off tomorrow me hey did you
hear that Midwestern mashup that was all
hash ups so sorry
oh no yeah tomorrow May 8th is when
Thanos will be playable but there are
certain conditions for which you can get
Thanos or Playa stano's so it's the
standard 100 person battle royale match
but the Infinity Gauntlet is gonna spawn
somewhere in the map I imagined randomly
and it has all six Infinity stones just
right in there there you go and if y'all
are caught up on your Marvel Lord you
know that the Infinity stones all have
their special individual powers but man
you'll get them in the gauntlet yo it's
it's so wild [ __ ] with that Oh for you
huh
yes and so in fortnight if you find it
and you equip it you yourself your
character will turn into Thanos but
there are no details as to how the
Infinity Gauntlet is going to work in
the game I will say so this looks a lot
like the Thanos model from the telltale
guardians of the galaxy series which I
reviewed the first couple episodes of
that he fits pretty well into the
fortnight yeah he looks terrible also
really quickly that looks exactly like
the Genji doesn't it look like Genji to
you yeah so overwatch Avengers 4 night
no I'm just kidding that'd be a crazy
that'd be too crazy that would be well
so anyway of course so an Entertainment
Weekly originally reported on this story
and so they got the quotes from the
Infinity Ward directors the Russo
brothers who are apparently huge
fortnight fans which is wild to me
they're one of the 60 million people
playing for now oh boy yeah I guess it's
not so wild um really quickly this is
available across all versions of
fortnight so even mobile
Joe Russo said to Entertainment Weekly
quote over the past few
while we were intending editing infinity
war we'd take breaks to hop on and get
in a few games and then we started
thinking how cool would it be to have
some kind of Avengers force a mashup
so we stalked Donald Donald mustard that
is the creative director at epic Donald
mustard so in response mr. mustard on
the beat said this out of the blue I get
this call from Joe Joe Russo that is and
after a bit of geeking out over each
other's work we start brainstorming
these crazy ideas it was really
important that whatever we did it had to
be super authentic to both fortnight and
adventures infinity war and something
that fans of both would be excited about
but um I mean continued about an hour
later we had the bones of this awesome
idea for a limited time gameplay mode
and almost immediately our team got
started you you really got to commend
them for the quick turnaround on this
one yeah all right
their battle royale mode itself you know
turn around yeah seriously yes I guess
fortnight is like the king of quick
turnarounds I almost said our GameSpot
word for King oh yeah which you know
what we've gotten to know you guys over
the past couple weeks of doing this show
but but maybe we're not quite there yet
we'll get there we'll reveal the
ultimate behind the secrets stuff to
y'all and maybe a couple weeks couple
months who knows stick around
um yeah I don't know I feel like okay
really quickly I'm just bear with me for
a second okay I do feel like maybe it's
a little weird for all the kids who are
playing spoilers for infinity or war
really quickly if you haven't watched it
Finn you won't skip ahead for like 30
seconds yes okay um just you know the
man who kills everybody
maybe weird to control him although you
control Darth Vader and battle from a
lot I don't think it's weird I'm just
surprised this flew oh right right
because this Jenna Seidel maniac who
kills his own child if you think about
it don't you think
danos would be like hella Opie like
hello yeah maybe that's the thing though
he destroyed easily yeah you just use
your feigning gauntlet BAM I'm the last
one standing peace out y'all but I mean
this I mean so when
fortnight came out with their season
Ford
which was the superheroes thing the
comet is hitting it changed dusty Depot
at the dusty divot did and then they
came out with like generic superhero
skins for the game so we're like oh this
is cool they're trying to capitalize on
the momentum around Marvel infinite
Marvel Marvel's Avengers affinity
Infinity Ward affinity affinity no
that's definitely not this is and yeah
we were just thinking like oh they're
just trying to capitalize on this is
kind of cool for season four and then
they came out with this like busted out
this is like weekend not just
capitalizing it we're collaborating yeah
we're going all-in I think it's really
cool I was just kidding about famous
being inappropriate children please
don't yell at me in the comments that
was just a joke I just think it's funny
yeah I think it's yeah it's something
but yes so again that Thanos will be
kicking off tomorrow we don't know
exactly what time tomorrow and when we
do know it's kicking off tomorrow so
keep an eye on that and I imagine that
here at GameSpot we're gonna be doing a
ton of content around you know we're
gonna try and find a nose or the
Infinity Gauntlet so we can turn into
nanos and then see what it does and
we'll probably have some features around
that we may even livestream it who knows
but new stories for sure
yeah so definitely keep an eye on
gamespot if you are curious I'm sure
we'll have like a usually our wonderful
news team does not like this thing is
live now so you know so I bet we'll
probably do something like that yep cool
and yes thank you for sticking around
this is GameSpot Daly again if you
didn't know and we're gonna jump into
our second story yes so if you're just
joining us now we talked about Dana
Thanos
thank that that Thanos don't drop that
the Bannos come into port night tomorrow
but we are now moving on to something of
we're always talking about our reality
really are that's just what 2018 is 2017
in 2018 yeah so anyway someone made a
GTA 5 mod that combines battle royale
and rogue light elements yeah this was
coming from PC gamer mm-hmm boy all
right so modder the etic
made a gta5 mod called complex control
the description is quote combining rogue
lights and battle royale elements like
we just said it feels as though there's
always something new to experience every
run that's kind of a cool concept yeah
it's a
mashing not not just bringing the
standard battery out but they're also
mashing in some other gameplay elements
on ice I was watching the the little
clip that they had for you which will
pull up in a minute so you check that
out as we talk you through some of the
details alright so right in a minute we
mean right now right Dan right [ __ ]
out okay whoa boy no way Michael alright
you'll be able to choose from one uh
from one of 70 characters and you guys
just that's for a mod they made 70
different characters to choose from as
well yeah so I think that they're all
gonna have their own unique superpowers
as to what degree they'll be different
who knows but maybe they're just skins
well that person that we had like a
blink yeah yeah so you get to choose
from 70 characters and the the point of
the game is that you get from zone to
zone almost like a king of the hill
style mode and you survive be like these
high fire zones I like AI come at you
and you guys survive that and within the
game there's a four level rank system
and uh but you also got a total career
score so there's a lot of statistic type
elements that are built into this mod
it's just not here we're dropping in the
new game mode so there's a lot of things
going on with that and they
quote-unquote have procedural gameplay
permadeath perma debt up and permanent
progression and to set it apart from
typical battle Royales that you have
seen cropping up in the past year year
and a half and this is according to the
mod creator via it via attic jannettek
anyway there's fifty power-ups including
teleportation like we saw in slo-mo
there's a separate save system from the
rest of GTA 5 so you have to worry about
things overlapping or crossing right
those wires motor Wars is also Battle
Royale style mode in GTA 5 that's from
August 2017 the smugglers run updates
there is like a battle royale esque mode
but of course with cars and it was none
of my created by roxor yeah that mode
dropped you into a zone with just 28
players though so it's not what a huge
please so the maximum of 7 teams we me
and Nick tried that out when it rolled
around the first time this little janky
he didn't really capture the spirit of
battle royale and you would you would
have thought that you know grand theft
auto of anything would be primed for a
battle royale conversion right
I mean especially if you're going to put
in the cars I mean the h1z1 has Auto
royale yeah which sounds like from what
you've told me does it better than it's
a similar concept done better oh it's
cool that GTA 5 is getting what sounds
like a more robust almost like hero
shooter styled with the 70 different
characters complicated battle royale and
of course a lot of people still play GTA
5 I think everybody knows that but it's
like consistently like the thing is it
keeps hitting the top of the UK charts
and over here we're like who still
doesn't have GTA 5 I know why are you
still behind GTA 5 last time we looked
at the sales numbers I think it was 90
million copies million 90 million copies
across all the different platforms so a
lot of people have GTA 5 out there and
this mod in particular which is also a
reminder it's called was it complex
comics complex control complex control
that is the mod name for GTA 5 that has
this better aerial Heuer
hero shooter mashup so you can check
that out I imagine it's free because
it's a mod so as long as I have GTA v on
pc i well yeah yes we should clarify
that mods are inherently for PC versions
also that story was from PC gamer yes
and that story was from PC gamer so yes
PC players of GTA 5 you can try out
complex control and yep so those are our
top lead leading stories of the day
those are our headline stories and so
again if you just jumping in now so we
talked about Thanos we talked about GTA
5 now we're just gonna totally switch
gears talk about Nintendo Nintendo
comments on switch sales versus we sales
not wii u wii to be to clarify because
when i first read this I was assuming it
would be Wii U um we we really quickly
this has nothing to do with mminton
Nintendo but my mom literally just
texted me Donald Glover might be the
coolest person on the planet there's a
real text my mom oh man yeah she's right
so anyway Nintendo Nintendo talks about
we sales versus fish sales intent I was
asked if the switch sales will ever
surpass Wiis sales for context we has
sold over
100 1 million units worldwide still
blows my mind it's a lot of wheeze yeah
[Laughter]
translated from an investor's QA this is
president Tut's Michi Mishima quote the
benchmark is not whether Nintendo
switched sales can surpass total we
sales but rather we adapt and respond to
changes in the market and strive to
continue selling Nintendo switch as long
as possible
I believe tux Miki Mishima is the new
president
he's the 46 year old dude who's taken
over the really young president that
just replaced the interim president
after a wad is passing this is like I
think one of the first things he's
publicly said as acting president oh man
he's inheriting a nice nice company
right there intentionally he's standing
on the shoulders of giants I guess is
how the saying goes the switch sold 17.7
9 million units last time Nintendo
reported numbers and they're aiming to
sell 20 million units during this fiscal
year which is April 2018 to March 29
yeah
Kimi Schmoe also said this for the
switches second year quote seeing how
far we can expand the market in the
second year of sales is incredibly
important for a video game system of
course whether it is a handheld system
or a home console system in the second
year the initiatives we are planning
come from our recognition that we are
also how we also have to challenge
ourselves to delivering Nintendo switch
into the hands of consumers who have
never played a Nintendo platform before
and those who have played it before as
well but not recently so there you have
that challenge of like trying to expand
their user base and you know getting
into people who wouldn't really play
video games or have been out of the
Nintendo loop for a while I think it's
directly referencing the Wii U era as
well call people who've played Nintendo
before but have lapsed recently that's
that to me sounds more like an
acknowledgment a very very roundabout
and tactful acknowledgement that the Wii
U that maybe there are people who have
elapsed a little bit I think Chris
Pereira our wonderful intrepid news
editor Chris Pereira mentioned that it's
it's worth talking about the fact that
has acknowledged before that the
potential of switch is higher than that
of a home a traditional home console
because you can sell switch to multiple
people / that's another thing is the
switch has the advantage of being a
console that can play like a home
console but also a handheld which makes
it more personal and like I know that if
it come out when my brother and I were
kids we would have to because they'll be
fighting a light yeah yeah some people
have like to ps4s in their house for
like convenience sake but I know a lot
of people who have kids and they have
their own switches and then their kids
want to play too but it's like yo you
ain't gonna play mine you gonna break it
yes oh they are they have a tendency to
buy one for you know their kids or you
know multiple four separate siblings and
this this is a lot more potential then
like attrition traditional we and
obviously they've already smashed the
sales on the Wii U so the potential is
much more higher it makes sense in that
regard and they're well on a they're
they're pacing for to reach some really
high sale numbers because like we said
almost 18 million in their first year of
release they plan on selling twenty
million more based on their based on
data I guess man think they're gonna hit
over a hundred million by the time the
the switches lifecycle runs out oh man I
mean with the games that just the games
that are on the horizon just like
knowing that there's a Pokemon game yeah
and Smash Bros and Metroid Prime for boy
I think I think some the thing is Kimmy
Schmidt did talk about like getting
people in who don't necessarily play a
lot of games I think that's something
that we sports did really well yes and
switch doesn't have a Wii Sports um all
the kind of you know so and I don't mean
just like a sports game that people like
to play I just mean like something that
super accessible something that's
accessible that shows the potential of
the system and games and brings you into
the games that that console has it
doesn't have that and I think that was a
big part of the Wiis success I I think
so too
like once you
which was I guess they're trying to be
that with once you switch but what's who
switch was I don't want to say it but it
was low-key trash
dad that's being harsh but like I mean
one Seuss which was a good display of
what the switch is capable of it just
didn't have any lasting appeal I mean
yeah we sports like I played bowling
with my homies for like two three years
straight when we were just like chillin
at his pad when we had the Wii so it's a
little different here but uh I don't
know
NPD has reported that the Nintendo
switch is the fastest selling console
yet in the United States in its first
year so the it's not too far-fetched to
believe that it could smash the Wiis
sales numbers did you you did this yes I
did okay finally also in March Nintendo
said there will be no switch 2.0 this
year as in like a an improved version of
the switch instead there will be more
peripheral based experiences like lava I
think that's interesting because for me
I feel like they were preparing kind of
for a switch to put on 2.0 with that
update back in October that enabled
system data recovery or system transfer
the way that you transfer with a 3ds for
me I was like finally if they come out
with one but with better battery life I
hope be there but it doesn't sound like
they're focused on that right now which
I think like it's fine but yeah I think
given the success that they've seen so
far and just wanting to put as many
games on that system as possible it
makes sense to not really focus on the
hardware itself yeah if anything if I
wanted to switch to our switch refresh I
think that maybe a bigger screen or like
covering up more of the covering more of
the bezels with actual screen space cuz
that was the first thing I saw I was
like oh man he's got some thick-ass
bezels and like oh man which screen is a
little bit bigger but it's fine
and maybe the Joye cons could probably
use a little bit more like the sticks on
the droid cons are a little stiff so
it's hard to play games like like doom
and imagines gonna come that's also
gonna come into a factor when
Wolfenstein 2 but I mean get a pro
controller it's all good yeah yeah
that's that's another thing is is just
when they say peripheral based
experiences it doesn't it sounds like
maybe new peripherals or maybe just
something that uses the Joye cons in
different way
yeah yes so the story of the day is that
the switch is doing extremely well uh
Nintendo commenting on switch sales
versus we sales okay so
switch versus the we here in 2018 man I
did see really quickly on cuz when I
read this headline I read switch versus
Wii U and the reason I read that is
because I saw a tweet or somebody was
comparing the Wii U library with the
switch library and being like the Wii U
has no good games the switch has all the
good games and it was just a list of all
the games that have been ported to
switch which i think is unfair because
if you've ever seen a gamepad that [ __ ]
is antiquated
although the Wii U gamepad yeah we
holding a gamepad in the year of our
Lord 2018 I'm like yeah it's a little
weird I I just think yes there's a lot
of fantastic games that were abandoned
we're lost in the wii era mm-hmm but
they are coming to like they're coming
is like Bayonetta is probably the most
most striking example of of the Wii U
Thant oh yeah well we got we know the
captain toad is on the way we know the
Bayonetta 2 is on the way on the switch
so it's like man they're covered in the
ground winwaker hid that needs to be on
switch right please if there's anything
else while we all want from the wii u
era its win waker HD I want to play Wind
Waker on my switch so bad Kimi Schmo if
you're listening Wind Waker HD on switch
and bring back the soul leading up to
Metroid Prime for also I'm asking you
personally trilogy yes Metroid Prime
trilogy cool boy thank you you're
welcome everyone yeah ok lastly so we've
this is our fourth and final story of
the day new Red Dead Redemption 2
screenshots released and special
editions confirmed so we know a lot of
people are probably really really high
for a Dead Redemption too
kind of hard to talk about screenshots
on a show like this we decided you know
what it's Red Dead Redemption - so
Rockstar released more screenshots on
its website Facebook Twitter and
Instagram we got all the shots in this
article
yes let's flip let's flip through them
that's that's your boy Arthur Morgan
right there well once that like overlay
goes away yeah there you go
there's some horses and cows Old
MacDonald had a farm John Marston mm-hmm
and Dutch that's your boy Dutch
vanderlin the leader of the gang gang
gang
that's my next cosplay all right that's
pretty dope snap wasn't worth our Morgan
in a hole up oh my god there's so much
happening on this page yeah ooh can't
fired this reminds me this song reminds
me of the stock of stalker shadows
normal oh yeah they also said that bow
and arrow is supposed to net you more
more Goods when you go hunting so you
can get to get more like wolf pelt
higher quality stuff
oh yeah cuz you're not ripping through
it with a bullet I guess or campfire
stuff
it's the gang mm-hmm oh boy oh oh not so
good boys actions that looks like wait
go back
is that Marsden sorry don't die I don't
want to like say today wrong so I'd
rather just not I know y'all are savage
out there yeah yeah yeah so um I don't
know how when it ends but we're gonna
keep going these images followed a batch
of six that came out last week
which can be found in our article on
Gamescom so if you want to check these
out for yourself
head on over to our website and you can
zoom in and examine these and come up
with your own theories cuz we do
apparently we got roasted but yeah again
if you don't know if you're not in the
loop Red Dead Redemption 2 follows the
story of Dutch vandal ins gang which
John Marcin was a part of and Arthur
Morgan who seems to be the leading
protagonist for this one it's been
heavily featured in a lot of the
trailers and a lot of the pre-release
materials and his latest trailer to the
trailer 3 which dropped last week you
can check that out it's a little bit
more sensitive it's a little bit more
introspective for Arthur Morgan himself
mm-hmm
what else what are we missing all right
you want to give the official
description I sure would sure what I'll
do that Red Dead Redemption 2 follows
the van der Linde gained 12 years before
the events of the first Redemption a
robbery goes wrong putting the gang on
the run with federal agents and bounty
hunters on their trail and the
description that you the official quote
is as deepening internal divisions
threatened to tear the gang apart Arthur
must make a choice between his own
ideals and loyalty to the gang who
raised him that seems yeah that that's
kind of in line with the the vibe of
trailer 3 which was like I said a lot
more introspective and our
there Morgan kind of kind of bumping
heads with some of his fellow gang
members so that's gonna be some be
really interesting I know Red Dead
Redemption is about Redemption so we're
gonna see pretty I suspect it's gonna be
a pretty wild character art for Arthur
morgan himself and also everyone loves
john marston so i'm really curious as to
how he's gonna factor into the story of
RDR - and you'll be able to find that
out if you have a ps4 and an Xbox one on
October 26 nicely done
we also have a history or at redemption
on GameSpot calm and you do if you want
to check that out the troubled history
of the development stuff about Red Dead
Revolver revolver and all that good
stuff that's something that I think is
definitely worth watching and you know
who did that video our good friend Jacob
Dekker so shout out to him he put
together history of Red Dead for you and
I watched that twice once last week and
once over the weekend and he gets in he
gets into some stuff you wouldn't have
thought otherwise because you know
obviously the Red Dead series only has
revolver and redemption one and we have
redemption 2 coming soon but there's
like a whole other backstory like you
mentioned that it's very interesting and
I think we'll get you a little bit more
hyped up for this game if you aren't
already hyped up already yep yep and
with that I think we're about done do
you want to do a quick what we're
watching in the anime world segment
watching well I caught up i watched the
new episode of my hero academia love in
that show
as you should as well and i caught up or
i I watched the persona 5 the new
episode for the persona 5 animation I
have a lot of thoughts and feelings
about that man I know why you should
really do a feature on that way I really
should but I just wanna say a few things
like some of the battle sequences are a
little lacking but it's just it just
feels so like when I watch and white
hear the music kick and I just all these
feelings come back from when I first
play and how it made me feel so it's
really capturing some of the that there
I know it goes by a lot a lot faster
because of the nature of an animation as
opposed to 100 hour RPG that's always
tough to capture but if anything I want
to say that the intro and the intro
music for the persona 5 animation is so
damn good brought me to tears no lie I'm
a grown-ass man but a that that intro
for p5 a brought me to tears man
being brought to tears a heretic Oh
brought me to tears the new Netflix
anime from the Sanrio from the Sanrio
from Sanrio
the company behind a Hello Kitty but is
not for children
there's misconception that Sanrio is
only for children but aggressive super
not for children it's an adult office
comedy about a red panda who sings death
metal karaoke because she hates her boss
who is literally a chauvinist pig he's a
pig and he's a misogynist that sounds
fun yeah it's excellent but the last
episode just got me and I was just
sobbing and then over the weekend I
watched interstellar for the first time
sobbing okay let's have it it's just
very emotional weekend free that I was
kept all interstellar was something I
knew was gonna make me cry for like
eight year four years eight years it's
been out for four years and I didn't
watch it I was just putting it off and
putting it off and and then I I've just
bit the bullet and I did it okay
cool though it was it's a fantastic
movie it just made me cry a whole lot
interstellar is not an anime though it's
not animal it wouldn't would it make
good for an anime adaptation anime
Matthew McConaughey no no no Matthew
McConaughey anime ah that's bad let's go
let's go before I take myself into a
deeper hole
um so stay tuned if you're watching live
we have a live stream coming up at 11:30
p.m. Pt a.m. Pt and it will be the
PlayStation Plus games for May which I
believe in includes beyond 2 souls and a
rayman game I think I think there's a
Raymond is it Man Legends that's what
our thumbnail is I forgot but yes so
we'll be streaming that if you're just
interested beyond 2 souls is one of
those games that can be a wild fun time
which we've experienced with other David
cage games before I think it can just be
really fun to just stick around in so
hot David cage joint as no one ever says
oh I was kidding you can check that out
though we'll be back tomorrow with more
news thank you for joining us as always
thank you to Matt Padgett and Tony
Wilson for getting our notes together
thank you Chris prayer because oh thank
you for what you do thank you Eric day
for always having our backs mmm I love
me some Eric Tay Thank You Emily Conte
the home girl always helping us get
ready in the morning
and as always thank you all for watching
we appreciate you and we love doing what
we do and we hope you love watching us
do our thing
goodbye bye